we've spoken about grape in on and off
yeah in the show right yeah and
did you guys know that one in 20 people
that are graped are men
do you know that yeah i knew one in five
years
one in 20. yeah and obviously men are
less likely
to
um
speak about it it's funny because i say
it's funny because even on here there
was a guy on here a few weeks ago who
said that he had like an essay situation
i'm not gonna lie i was listening to it
i was like
really and i had to check myself like
wow like i'm really questioning that and
i'm a man so you're not supposed to
believe him
well i was supposed to at least like
hear him out but when i heard it i was
like ah but then i was like oh my god
you're doing that
that women would would consider essay
then yeah it happens daily when it comes
to women to men like it happens all the
time you know i've definitely had
women come up to me and just sort of go
grab you and go for the crap
i think
then exactly because i just went like
that that's that's is that essay then
would you say if a woman does that to
you i would well
because technically it is by the
standards that
women have set but i actually think
lesbians get away with that as well
well like ellen she got away with i
can't remember who she groped but she
did grope someone in the picture without
their consent mm-hmm um so and i think
so basically women are allowed to wait
did not wait did
did that person press charges
no but they did look uncomfortable
but i'm saying if yeah okay it's like
then press charges i think like i just
don't i don't just believe people just
because they say things like anyone can
say something go press charges yeah and
also on your point of when um
so i've got your name so sorry sorry i
asked you you were like oh you know
that's the problem the thing is we need
to call things out more and you know
because
one thing that does make me sad is the
fact that you know
men are higher um suicide rates and
investing all those kind of things
because
you know and much as you're saying no
one cares what have you okay is the
cycle going to care about you let some
therapy therapist or someone because in
the day you are you you are kidding
yourselves and
ultimately
like we do need men like you know much
as women i mean twitter is i mean social
media ultimately is a place where if you
indulge in it enough you would think all
men hate women or women hate men you
know racism at war over time and the
rest of the rest of it but if you take
that away and look at your life as a
person individual ultimately
you need a man in your life you want a
man in your life so i think and and we
need you guys so yes we say and pull up
and make your money no difficult but if
if you don't feel loved and you don't
feel care then you need to talk to
someone because ultimately i do need you
i agree how are we gonna how are we
gonna have kids i'm not even one four
kids but
ultimately we do and especially in the
black community we need you guys like we
can't lead ourselves and we know that
and i think that's half the frustration
i think when from black women about
you know of the frustration of us what
leaders and once when certain men you
know so we're not saying kill yourself
and no one cares like yes twitter and
touch me to make you feel that way but i
think in our communities and what have
you we do care we do want you guys to be
there for us and with us what do you
think guys
i agree yeah
that that sounds
i think it's a lovely lovely message but
then you look at some of the dynamics
that
you see in relationships
and
some of the advice that girls are
getting from their friends
and it
it goes completely in contrast to the
single friends
not every single friends a lot of people
are donuts my issue is that we're not
reading enough we're not actually
educating ourselves back in the day i
don't have the social media to go and
ask them to go and ask a question and
then for me to make a formal opinion on
that question a lot of girls will be
like i will never do that
men say i will never do that my men have
told me they will never get the girl
after cheating him i know people have
done that on on the cover but they've
done it but my women say if a man
cheated me i'll leave him these things
might actually happen in real life it's
true it's only on social media we have
an opinion but the average that if you
look at the average family or the
average people around you i've got
friends in love with relationships i've
got friends in abusive relationships
it's all very different but if i go on a
social media and look at when i pick one
thing i'm going to only get one thing
and i and i've realized that myself that
i was on a path of hating men that know
all men of trash was a really fun
statement to say you know and grow
around all my trash but ultimately i
have i have i have for people in my life
men that are not trash i had to ask
yourself where did those opinions come
from from a lot of these young girls i
don't they haven't got sense
and if you're and if you if you haven't
got said if you haven't got a sense you
haven't got a sense you shouldn't be a
man in the purpose anyway do you think
that message comes from the media and
music what the women are trash
um i would say it's definitely a bit of
birth i mean for music for me i don't
necessarily
for me it's at the time it's a story
because same way alice is like you
fastest gangster happens other certain
things about killing people what have
you you know i don't take that on so
therefore i'm gonna take on you know the
weapon whatever else they're saying i
just you know if i wanted if i wanted
for that like i'm a stripper i put some
card it be i wish
if i wanted it because it's
because well it's because everything's
catered towards women and women are
bailed out of every bad decision that we
make
do you think yeah i mean okay okay think
about it okay if a woman sleeps around
right yeah well she's bailed out with
birth control if that fails would she
bailed out with an abortion if that
fails would she build out with child
support if that fails which or if she
gets married and that fails what what's
she bailed out with alimony or child
support again
it's like if a woman is bad with her
finances and she's homeless what does
she have a woman's shelter there's not
men's shelters not like that there's not
like they're men's rights issues it's
always women's rights issues if a woman
is unhappy about something there's
marches if a woman doesn't like men's
standards there's fat shaming
slut-shaming like it whatever we do and
there's a potential consequence like we
are bailed out or told who's supporting
like
women is it just women supporting or is
it
because the world is made of men and
women i would say i would say it's beta
ass dudes that like they're trying to
get laid so they push the [ __ ] forward
even though they know it's nonsense and
women because the emotion is the order
or or money like the rolo tomasi shout
out um says if you want to make a
million dollars like convince give
sell women the fear of missing out and
something that makes them look younger
i mean that's just some [ __ ] which is an
emotional it's an emotional thing
you spoke earlier women deal with their
emotions more so than their logic but
i'm gonna read super chat i'm gonna read
super chats real quick so
um guys um we are gonna turn on members
only mode for the second half of the
stream so if you want to be a part of
the chat um we're turning on members
only mode now
on top of that guys we are trying to get
issue camera i think it's coming in soon
it's coming in it's it's hopefully
saturday yeah hopefully saturday's show
we can get issue camera what is the next
thing we should save for um
next thing we should what should we what
should we buy next
for a couple of days a couple ideas we
can we could talk about it later okay
we'll talk we'll talk
um but let me know in the chat what we
should get next also guys there is 2 300
of you in here and there's not a
thousand likes the audacity like this
goddamn video come on
like the video let's get to a thousand
likes in here also guys
like our facebook page like our twitch
page and follow my instagram it's
just.purlythings so we also got twitter
as well oh yeah and i'm on twitter oh my
gosh i have too many things to plug i
forget